Kevin Taylor, Managing Director for the BT
in Asia Pacific. It's a great question. I
believe China is half the bridge towards recovery,
the investment. The Chinese government has
made into the infrastructure in China has
helped also increase growth by 30% or- which
is excellent. But half the bridge only, the
other half of the bridge is the US. I'm definitely
seeing early signs of recovery in terms of
planning over the last three or four weeks
and feel very confident that as we see the
next six months to one year we'll see much
more positive environments for doing business.
China has played its part; it's also supported
the dollar in the process. I know their dollar
is finding lower pressure at the moment same
as-- situation so let's pray to pass in the
world economy and I think we can look forward
to better times. Thank you.